how's it going bro my name
is welcome oh you bro wanted it here's
more of it
slender someone's humping a fence in the
background I was hoping I didn't have to
play this game
anymore I was wrong all right so I guess
there's two ways you can go here I don't
know which I usually pick that's a tree
and I think this is the penis let's go
for the penis I don't see why
not is that a dog or an
owl we will never know Unity games are
becoming a lot more popular it's it's
great to see I I love um simple Indie
Horrors it's good fun good fun I hope
they make like an update of this game
that would be great that' be good times
not for me for you there's a note first
note spotted and no SL slendy SPID how
about that slendy H slendy sucks F an
octopus man look at that [__] slendy
thinks he's cool and
all I'm way cooler than you
slendy
way okay I'm not cooler I'm sorry then
you take it back we're friends right you
and me homeboys we can go out and do
some tentacle stuff together I don't
have tentacles though but I mean I bet
you have some octopus buddies that we
can hang out with that'd be pretty
cool a [__] I'm getting Shivers again
there no buo M no buo it's very good
Spanish I got there I
know I don't even know how to find eight
notes how the [__] am I going to find
eight
notes tree don't stand in my way tree
hey ooh hello
there can run running right
now what is these
pictures I want this
paper no not
already ah son of a
[__] that's no way now maybe if I turn
off the flashlight be really
quiet
hello he can't he's too fat come in
here I think I
L no
no a I'm so stupid well that proves
every
thanks
[__] I got so many comments saying he
doesn't see you if you have a flashlight
on you asshol you're lied to
me what the
[__] never listening to comments
again all right let's hop in there let's
do
it thank you bros thanks for that I
appreciate it appreciate all the
comments I get that's so
useful I don't know why everyone has so
many ideas about this game oh if you
don't use the flashlight he won't see
you [__] I tell
you [__] [__] he sees you when
you're
sleeping he creeps when you're awake he
uses tentacle arms to [__] rape your
ass to skate you better watch out you
better not Bend Over You better not
not pick up notes I'm telling you why
slender will rape you
tonight it's a bit low it's a bit low
key I got one note that means he's up by
ass he's probably mooning and doing
weird [__] behind me right
now he's probably flipping me off or
some [__] with those arms of his maybe
doing some yoga [__] just to taunt me I
wouldn't be surprised I'm Not Looking
Back slendy I don't care Not Looking
Back the red car is zoom in like a [__]
like a [__] like a wouldn't it be funny
if slender sat in the car no take that
back would not be funny slendy don't do
it hey a
door says leak no it doesn't could have
said help me I'm not going to help you
house it doesn't matter what you say
house I'm in trouble too house I'm sorry
okay how I'm coming back for
you stupid [__] I'm not coming back
for
anyone all
right how many do we have I lost count
two all right Bueno progressor as mtio
let's run a little I got the feeling he
up my ass
again it tickled what did you do think
someone touched
me' be funny if they had Barrels in this
game it's such a suspense suspenseful
game if I happen to shout barrels I know
a lot of people will lose their prostate
what that's not how you say it let's
just pray for a note pray for yes no I
mean yes yes
yes I don't even care he's behind me I
don't even care I don't I'm going to
look back and not going to look back I
don't see why I shouldn't look back I'm
Not Looking Back In My atole
I don't want him to scare me cuz he make
me feel so good make me feel so good
singing isn't helping me getting less
scared it's not helping at all it's not
helping at
all it's not at all not B me at all no
there's no note in here
no
no no why is a no no a [__] all right
fine Plan B I don't have one [__]
everything and run that's my plan B all
right don't lose breath
[__] shake your tits a little bit
you'll be fine girl we're in this
together Astic stuff it's got to be an
not on these
[__] has to be is it
you I see it because of
clipping I don't know if that's
technically what whatever I don't care
I'm taking you with me you always watch
I'm out of here four no B that's a ja
reference can
something all right that's fine that's
fine containers
containers containers containers
containers that's fine we haven't even
seen slandy he is probably tickling my
butt right
now another one no no no no there wasn't
another one
well where the [__] is
it yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
come here leave me alone container no no
no no no no I hate this Ambiance no no
no I I don't even want to [__] look
ah ah ah house my house in the middle of
the [__] creep Forest my house okay
it's Slender's house I'm sorry don't
join me in here
all right so good oh look what a nice
entrance that is fantastic we have five
notes
[__] all right h no one in here
that's cool that's totally fine with me
Miss oh
no
wait oh [__]
[__]
was so close why did I run I lost track
of where I was
running I gotta pee can't you see can't
you see that I gotta
pee we're not making any progress with
this are
we I'm trying I swear to God I'm trying
the best I [__] can but uh yeah that
was pretty pretty good run pissed my
pants I'm ready to go and peer now oh
wait never mind it's already
done all right Bros um like a faod if
you enjoyed so I can buy new pants and
I'll see you next episode of whatever I
make stay awesome BR I know you
well how do you do
that what the [__] what the [__] okay up
up up up up up up no bad bad seal
what the hell Tania ah